Diane is in Jackson Mississippi hi Diane
how are you hi thank you for taking my
call day sure what's up I have a 21 year
old daughter who's going to get her
associate's degree in May he doesn't
know what she wants to do with her life
so she wants to move to Colorado and she
has planned she's saving money she ready
to go working the tourist industry or
whatever it takes okay mm-hmm so I saved
money for her to go to a 4-year
institution to complete her degree so I
want to know what you think should I did
I give her part of the money should I
save it in case she comes back and needs
it or should I use it to pay off my car
um how much money 20,000 okay on a scale
of one to ten ten being very excited how
excited are you about the path she's
taking in her life zero well then we're
not going to finance a zero okay I don't
get my money went to stuff I don't
believe in right because basically what
you're doing is you think this is crazy
now you're right being you're thinking
about financing crazy you're right why
would I do that
you know no I'm not doing that so I
didn't get that out of the park first
part I thought maybe it was a six or
seven I didn't get the zero when you
first were talking but zero interest it
instantly you know if my kid is doing
something and wants me to give my money
to something that I think is not good
for them why would I you know finance
things that are going to harm that are
not good the best possible thing for
them so no I wouldn't do that
now then the question is how much money
twenty thousand okay and what's your
household income eighty and what do you
owe on your car 19 okay that's the only
debt I have okay and you're single
though I think I take it I know sir I
have a husband okay and you have any
other money saved I have a little bit
more and I have retirement what's a
little bit more I have about ten
thousand more in a money market and then
I've got like sixty thousand in
retirement and you know it's a little
additional okay income and I'm working
several jobs okay good for you
I my first step is I'm gonna set the
money aside and I'm going to tell kiddo
hey kiddo I love you so much
and if you want to live an adventure I'm
not gonna like this on you or something
but I don't think this is a wise move
yeah and so it is incumbent upon me as a
loving mom and dad to not give you money
to finance something that we don't think
is good for you yeah we could be wrong
and you may come back in the you know in
glorious style and this is the best move
you ever made in your life and you know
I sometimes I'm wrong but I'm but I
don't think I am here I think I think
you're chasing something that ain't
there kiddo and and I'm not gonna pay
for that
but what I am gonna do is I'm gonna set
this money aside and if you choose to
get back on the track within the next
couple of years it'll be there okay I'm
gonna leave that carrot lay in there I
don't have a real frank conversation and
with her dad to by the way yeah her bad
you know needs to say this she doesn't
just need to hear moms and daughters
sometimes don't connect as well as a dad
yeah he may not be a man of a lot of
words but if he says a few she might
hear might hear that a lot more and she
hears her mom I could be wrong that
might have been true of my house wink
wink um so but you know so that that you
know what I'm gonna try to do here is
leave that as a carrot to try to get her
back on track cuz there's money in your
mind that was hers you're pretty
disgusted with her right now so you
kinda like half a car
heck with it you know like I don't blame
you for having those emotions but I from
now on suicide but then I would say and
this deals not forever by being
different money gonna be here ten years
from now right I'm gonna use it but if
in the next couple of years and I maybe
put a two-year mark on it or something
like that if you come back around you
want to go back to school and you want
to finish your degree and you want to do
some stuff or you want to you know be on
a track that we're excited about we
might help you with this money to do
that but this is our money it's but it's
kind of got your name on it for two
years after two years honey we're just
gonna use the money okay and or
something like that I mean you see what
I'm saying but yeah let's give her a
little time to turn the corner she may
go out there and just hit the wall my
right back it's possible okay you know
some of us need to get you know since
knocked into it and life life's pretty
good about helping you do that so I
wished I wish we didn't all have to
learn the hard way but some of me
included hard heads have to be learned
you know and stuff the hard way so I
give her a little grace there let's set
that money aside and then after or some
period of time you can decide you and
your husband inside the period of time
two years sounds right but I could be
wrong maybe it's 18 months I don't know
it's not five I wouldn't hold it five
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh